[Music]
this week we've got storm sliders funny
coincidence and the prodigy tattoo is
taking away eight people need yeah so
for our first story
did you guys hear this typhoon that hit
Hong Kong no oh is that what Donnie Yen
was posted about I don't know so he was
it man I follow him and then he was like
today I'm going to stay inside because
of typhoon something and I'm like I
don't even know what he's talking about
hate oh yeah yeah well on Twitter on
Instagram on video oh today I'm going to
stay inside yeah there are like crazy
was it like when it's pretty air heady
was it like live or was it like one of
those recordings you just record any
post it was even a story like it was a
video yeah today I've got this name I
saw his interview where was it on like
Jay Leno or something and then the host
our out who it was he's like so what
type of martial art do you do he's like
uh you know I I don't really know he was
English is like [ __ ] no but here I don't
know [ __ ] dogs weird like it was like
the worst interview I've ever seen and I
lost so much respect Guardian you're
[ __ ] awesome I love it I still love
you but you gotta get better interviews
dude yeah your people her people are not
I think people like think it's kung-fu
but he's actually Taekwondo he didn't
even know no one will ever know cuz he
didn't know like look what was it what
your specialty what are you good at I
think it was trying to be so American
with like all these like expressions I
don't yeah maybe socially awkward as you
can fight the [ __ ] out of people maybe
like some artists yeah or maybe he gets
like stage fright like will I am [ __ ]
not William you be black-eyed peas like
no there's a
the other guy taboo Apple or Apple one
of those but he's there's the Filipino
one there's the black and white one that
looks kind of like native or Pocahontas
style a tender stuff black black guys
know the guys later he was promoting a
phone like attachment like a lens
attachment he's like oh um it's it's not
a fashion piece but if you wear it it's
a fashion piece and people like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like he's
socially awkward as hell I think it also
depends on these celebrities like if you
catch them while they're high Oh were
they ready for the interview or did they
just use a lot of different I was stoned
that day maybe man was stoned
maybe it's branding because um I was
told that there's is one a band where
the lead singer was a Japanese and she's
also like American too oh no no no no
she was Japanese born bushing with to
America and she speak English really
well right and so when they bead with
her band she was like seeing her songs
in like English and stuff right but like
when she went over to a concert in Japan
her PR her PR was telling her like hey
you should just continue to speak
English even though we know you speak
fluent Japanese just to keep up with the
branding so like during the whole time
like no her boss their PR people are
like just sound I don't know like
because like because she's well Japanese
fluently so like she could talk to her
Japanese fans in Japanese but then her
PR team was like no just stay in English
your branding should be consistent maybe
it's more exotic that way like it's like
a foreign musician anyway Trump I know
you speak English
but I want you to sound like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] please that's too bad there's a
video that I saw the typhoon earless
construction cranes the huge ones yeah
it was spinning around like Oh is there
is there video yes I'm gonna show you
guys a clip I don't have that clip
that's crazy I'm scared of that stuff I
don't know just you guys know there were
12 people killed in this tano so it's
bad but that's scary
it's that strong it was like a category
three hurricane I don't know what that
is - the highest category it could be
that's like oh my god
dude that [ __ ] hitting the [ __ ]
building is [ __ ] Wow pushed over a truck
holy [ __ ] you see all the people flying
dude what that is great is that Endor I
was like a docking area huh what the
[ __ ] does that part it's like the
typhoon is making adults do what they
don't want to do but kids love that but
you know if it's like a wet slippery
surface kids will love to slide so it's
it's sad that the dots like no don't do
it but I feel like for kids to like go
out and play ya know there's something
called typhoon babies what is that which
I learned about an Okinawan cuz they
have sacraments over there when it's
typhoon season and there's a big one
hitting everyone has to stay indoors and
they can't do [ __ ] for days stay [ __ ]
and then they have babies and those are
considered typhoon babies oh that's like
a pick-up line okay now that is crazy
when a person looks like a [ __ ] piece
of flag holding all I know believe that
truck tipped over
I know ho yeah it was pretty insane but
I kind of want to feel that in a safe
way I kind of feel that what there's a
strong winds I'm like time I waste a
little that I'm like wow you need to
hold on cuz then I remember walking to
a power lifting event it was hella windy
and all day you thought you're gonna get
blown away it feels like it I got to get
push I'm like you might and you gained
some weight I never felt that with the
wind I would like to feel that one day
like I'm not yeah what are you talking
about we're like the same but anyways
moving on to the next or anything yes we
are look at you
good tiny anyway the next story it was
kind of funny but ESPN in order for them
to try to avoid something they just made
it worse and what happened was they had
this loan when people do that they had
this Asian American announcer named
Robert he's gonna be announcing the
University of Virginia home opener
football game but since what happened in
Virginia recently with the protests in
in Charlottesville they decided to
remove the patient American anchor
presenter but they decided to move the
asian-american announcer because of his
name being so similar to robert e lee so
to try to make it better replace him
like you think removed here they removed
it yeah they're trying to make it better
I don't even think people remember
history like that this is Robert Lee
robert e lee Bashan yeah and so now like
we've just got so much crap for it we
wouldn't want any mistake I guess maybe
they're thinking about the radio this is
Robert Lee report yet where you don't
see the face yeah and it's like oh my
god he's back from the dead the
Confederate [ __ ] general robert e lee
they were like foreshadowing the you
know the tweets and the memes of that
stupid I could see it now
we're gonna be the laughingstock of the
whole [ __ ] news
yes p.m. you [ __ ] up hard now you
really are [ __ ] a laughingstock what
I'm eating it how did they how did they
how do people even find out about do you
know so apparently there was this one
website called out cake that covered the
story they actually broke the story with
the headline saying MS ESPN mrs. Espen
which are making fun of ESPN calling it
like MSNBC which is a liberal talk show
or they have liberal talk shows and so
they're saying emeth ESPN pulls asian
announcer named robert lee up uva game
to avoid offending idiots they were
saying that this article is so popular
that the site servers were overloaded
because there were so many people
sharing the story oh and they were just
saying like they're babying everything
now that's a point where they can't even
have an announcer name similar to a
confederate dude i don't blame yes P&O
what i blame is the current status of
American society but they're
contributing [ __ ] they're so [ __ ]
sensitive it's no flaking [ __ ] ass even
we see it in the [ __ ] comments
I'm on a blocking role [ __ ] I'm
gonna stop blocking all your
[ __ ] and I don't like it
because I miss how it used to be
and everyone's sensitive everyone's
getting mad everyone's trolling
everyone's talking mad [ __ ] [ __ ]
so ESPN is hyper like I don't know what
to do man I don't know yeah because
everyone's hyper sensitive with
everything like you have any sort of
opinion on anything your brother scared
of free thinkers alright or alt laughter
I think they should have left it up to
show that whoever gets mad at this is a
[ __ ] idiot
they shouldn't purposely put things up
like that you should yeah I'm bringing
back David's kill yourself slogan if I
can see you hang people crying in those
if you hate living on this planet
[ __ ] do it and the funny thing is
like how do you know if they're there 12
year olds trolling pertaining to be an
adult like you don't [ __ ] know you
don't know where these comments are
coming from
so the
words of can don't believe to comment
there's this photo I had a to like
braids on my hair some [ __ ] idiot
that's racial a cultural appropriation
to black cornrows I'm like [ __ ] someone
the one that I'm wearing today raids are
not owned by pens do you know how many
Mexican people [ __ ] do it like yeah
[ __ ] you guys then the French invented
the French brain yeah if someone is like
if a black girl did my braids like that
and called it a cornrow she would get
fired immediately because they were so
loose
these [ __ ] you people what about all the
black girls I have Asian names like
China China black choice are you eating
cares who gives a [ __ ] flattery yeah
it's one of those things where it's like
they just want to feel so important like
I'm offended by this person yeah it
waters down like real struggle and real
offense yeah it really does
yeah if you say something like
minorities still have a long way to go
as far as being represented in the u.s.
fairly then people go oh my god you're a
[ __ ] live [ __ ] you're such a [ __ ]
left-wing communist Democrat
[ __ ] why are you such a social
justice warrior I'm like what dude I'm
just making out a statement I saw your
tweet about the starving children
yeah well five Mike yeah like yeah I own
guns and I am for gun ownership oh look
at this white worshipping [ __ ]
you're not even Asian anymore it's like
what what the [ __ ] like why can't people
just be moderate in the by Asian guns
right Asian good yeah you can't you
can't be a moderate anymore you can't
pick and choose like sometimes I like
democratic ideas sometimes I like
Republican ideas I want gay people have
guns all of my bullets are made in
Korean by PMC's you cheap someone's
gonna get offended watch I know right if
you get offended like David said please
kill yourself yeah make a clorox
cocktail drink the [ __ ] out of it we're
bringing this [ __ ] back
brigadiere [ __ ] because that JK we
don't want to raise little [ __ ]
alright moving on to our last story
there is this 12 year old that is trying
to be a tattoo artist
oh nothing wrong with that that's pretty
cool yeah in Florida is namath is rough
Ezra Ezra which i think is a pretty cool
name a very nice name
yes his parents do tattoo so his parents
are artists and apparently they had this
get-together this one night and it was
kind of like a tattooing get-together
apparently and so his mom was getting a
tattoo done on her wrist and she was
getting a flower so Israel was
commenting to the woman tattooing you
suck no he was like that's so cool like
that's so awesome I wish I could try
that sometime and like he was just like
really eager to try to learn
Ezra's like man I could [ __ ] man you
shouldn't be tattooing you suck I could
do it better no and then that's when Ali
the tattoo artist she said right now so
then why what's on her skin on his mom
so then what the mom lets you you can
yeah I know but you could like slice
your mom up and [ __ ] it's not a big deal
no it's not little boyfriends and
girlfriends they tattoo each other for
the first time all the time I've seen
those shitty tattoos old man so bad well
he did all he did was fill in a colored
area so it wasn't like she was doing
lines or anything
it's like extreme coloring book yeah
and so now apparently he's done about 20
tattoos yeah 20 already so he's a he's
an apprentice at this tattoo shop he's
apprentice thing under Ali and he's just
learning he loves it he's just really
looking forward to his yard he got his
man button going on yeah he already has
hipster so he already looks cool the
official artists ready he had his tattoo
already yeah he was saying that when he
went to school and he was telling his
friends like none of them believed him I
can't write you don't talk to anybody
but then he was like you know he's one
of those kids at school that probably
has like a cool young parent that lets
him do like cool [ __ ] and then it's like
you see them at school and you're like
man [ __ ] you dude
like my parents are so old and
conservative or maybe not yet you know
you're not a free thinker until like
maybe high schoolish so maybe they're
like still very conservative
conservative like their parents are like
that's a shame look at this poor kid
he's gonna be trash you know need cuz
you still think like your parents Oh
like someone's our kids that like that
our dick writers because not cuz this
kid was the kind of kid that I would be
like man well I want to be your friend
but I'm so jealous I wish I could do
that yeah I wanna bet Elementary I
didn't like all the cannot not I didn't
like I was jealous of the kids that were
like they could dress younger their
parents dressed them up because their
parents were young and they got to do
all the cool [ __ ] like watch you marry
what children they did all that like
their parents took him to like skate
parks and all that stuff and I'm just
like man my parents want me to dress
like a little [ __ ] so his parents are
really supportive of Israel and his
dreams and they're saying that you know
he's been going often to go study under
Elly and he practices on grapefruits and
he's even he's did his first lines on
his dad I'm so cool yeah he's like you
know I'm really looking forward to the
future like when I can just make a
living off of my tattoo gun and I could
just travel the world and just have my
size your gun on me to make money are
there photos of his tattoos no I want to
see what if it's like you should be like
the one remember and when I do my
tattoos of Geo he was like the flowers
of [ __ ] flowers don't see what they
weekly I'm jealous of this kid there
were some tattoos that they're showing
but since they're saying that he mainly
like fills in colors ah the dart like he
apparently he really likes the
old-fashioned style of tattooing like
they're like mom yeah by good people
like the Sailor Jerry yeah Marikana type
stuff my stuff hey guys thanks for
watching that last video make sure to
follow us on instagram @ JK films to
watch more videos right up there
[Music]